[Music]
I'm speaking with general mattis we're
going to be doing things military later
until we can have a wall in proper
security we're going to be guarding our
border with the military we have
horrible horrible and very unsafe laws
in the United States hopefully soon
hopefully Congress will get their act
together and get in and create some very
powerful laws like Mexico has and like
Canada has and like almost all countries
if we don't have laws we have
catch-and-release
we will be doing things with Mexico and
they have to do it otherwise I'm not
going to do the NAFTA deal well the
president talking about immigration
talking about NAFTA talking about how
he's going to shore up the southern
border with the US military now the
Mexican ambassador to the US who we had
on special report last night is asking
for an official clarification from the
US government on exactly what's going to
happen let's bring in our panel and
start there matthew cottan Ettie
editor-in-chief for the washington free
beacon Mar Alliance and national
political correspondent of National
Public Radio and Katie Pavlich news
editor at townhall.com okay Mara the
president was on a tear tweeting and
talking both in the news conference and
at the Cabinet Room a lot about the US
military along the border yep and this
is a dramatic tough action that he can
send a message yes I'm doing something
about illegal immigration even though I
couldn't get funding for my wall in the
Omnibus that's the context for this he's
very frustrated about that and he's
gotten some pushback from the base
because of that this has been done
before george w bush and barack obama
used the National Guard to supplement
Border Patrol agents when there was a
big surge of illegal immigrants coming
over the border whether there is one now
or not we don't know and we don't know
exactly what the president means when he
says we're gonna have the military on
the border but that's something that he
was meeting with general mattis about
and the defense secretary and they're
gonna figure it out okay
well I would say it's not just about
illegal immigration on the border it's
about deterrence with cartel and violent
operations that are happening there as
well now this will probably be welcomed
by the governors of Arizona and Texas it
will not be welcomed by the governor of
California to be sure but this does go
at hand-in-hand
with the administration's talking points
and push this week to end catch him
release and to me the president
announcing he wants the military on the
border we don't know how for exactly how
long that's going to be he says he wants
to be until the wall is built but
considering George W Bush had the
National Guard there for two years
President Obama had them there for about
a year and three months it might not be
for as long as it takes to build the
wall because that will take longer
probably than his presidency but he's
clearly sending a message of deterrence
by putting the military there when he's
talking about preventing people from
coming here because our own immigration
laws allow people who get here from
certain countries the majority of them
to stay and it becomes more of a problem
for our legal system than does in terms
of borders and he talked about that
today to Matthew about the the fact that
these folks come in they seek asylum and
essentially the court system is
overwhelmed 700 days is the average now
to get from the point of the border to
an actual hearing you could make an
argument that immigration politics got
Donald Trump the Republican nomination
and helped him win the presidency so
this is a natural issue for him you know
when he was inaugurated president border
illegal border traffic dropped
precipitously it's now been slowly
climbing back up and so I think Haley is
right a lot of these moves are to
reestablish the deterrence to say that
that we're going to police this border
there are legislative restrictions on
what the military can do once they're
dispatched there and they typically
serve an advisory role a logistical
logistical role to free up the actual
Border Patrol and all of this is
happening the same time Brett that Trump
is exploring ways that the Department of
Defense can help fund the wall which is
the main object here I think right and
you know funding is the big question
meantime talking about the serious
situation asked a question about US
troops in Syria it's time we were very
successful against Isis we'll be
successful against anybody militarily
but sometimes it's time to come back
home I want to get out I want to bring
our troops back home I want to start
rebuilding our nation will be consulting
also with the groups of our people and
groups of our allies with Saudi Arabia
is very interested in our decision and I
said well you know you want us to say
maybe you're gonna have to pay maybe we
have to pay Saudi Arabia Gulf states
meantime at the same time almost the
exact same time the u.s. counter Isis
envoy Brett McGurk was saying this to
reporters we are in Syria to fight Isis
that is our mission and the mission
isn't over and we're going to complete
that mission so you know there's a
obviously the president is is laying
groundwork here for pulling out of that
operation but when it's done is really
the question right when it's done and if
he pulls out too soon does he create a
vacuum that's filled by Russia and Iran
and gives us a chance to regroup this is
exactly what he ran against when he
criticized Barack Obama for putting a
date certain on pulling troops out of
Iraq he said the bad guys are just going
to wait you out and that's why you have
a lot of military experts saying this is
not a good idea as much as Donald
Trump's deepest instincts are come home
use that money to rebuild our nation
he's kind of a hawkish non
interventionist if there is such a thing
but but this is going to be tough for
him to figure out how to do this but
think about that soundbite we just
listened to Katy and his new incoming
national security adviser John Bolton
and how those two things track it's
obviously the president who makes policy
Bolton would be an adviser but clearly
he would think otherwise I mean giving
end date without an actual time stamp is
counter to what the administration has
said that they're going to do and you're
absolutely right about john bolton
coming in as a national security adviser
it's going to be very interesting to see
how getting out of syria no matter when
that is couples with the
administration's new plan on iran when
the president releases national security
strategy iran was the main focus rahm
was the main focus under general
McMaster is still the main focus it is
interesting to see him talking about the
Saudis however he understands that the
Saudis have a vested interest in making
sure that that part of the region is
stabilized and he said all along other
countries who have an interest there
need to step up the Saudis seem like in
the last couple of months they're
willing to do that but if they're going
to continue to be tough on Iran as
they've laid out in their strategies
before Syria
taking Syria of the pictures when a very
very difficult finally I want to just
touch on this other issue and that is
Amazon where the president has really
stepped up the attacks tickle ISM you
take a look at the post office and the
post office is losing billions of
dollars and the taxpayers are paying for
that money because it delivers packages
for Amazon and a very below cost and
that's not fair to the United States
it's not fair to our taxpayers and
Amazon has the money to pay the fair
rate at the post office which would be
much more than they're paying right now
so Amazon is gonna have to pay much more
money to the post office so Matthew this
is kind of well it is unprecedented for
a president to go after one company with
tweets and statements the post office
doesn't operate on taxpayer money it's a
paid for service they obviously operate
in buildings and facilities that are
that they don't have to pay taxes on but
what about how the president's
describing all of this Amazon and the
post office do have some type of special
contract but no one really knows the
details of and I do notice as a frequent
buyer of books both from Amazon proper
and from the used book stores that
retail and I Amazon I find the Amazon
packages get there much more quickly
than the ones that have to go through
the regular post-office Channel let's
say Donald Trump is a populist figure oh
that's interesting we're gonna do a
study there Trump is people tend to view
this in terms of Trump's relationship
with Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos but I think
one stream of communication he's getting
is from all of his people in the
commercial real estate business and
industry who had been really hard hit by
the changing nature of the retail
economy Donald Trump tends to think in
terms of tangible objects and so I think
what's bothering him here among many
other things is a sense that our economy
is shifting in a way that his friends
who deal in small retail businesses or
commercial property like malls are
losing out to this major Internet giant
let's just say if he woke up tomorrow
and said you know Walmart's
picking out mom-and-pop stores to look
there's two things going on one is
there's a lot of retail in Trump Towers
around the country and there and he's
probably suffering along with everybody
else but this idea that the President of
the United States would go after a
individual company why isn't the Chamber
of Commerce having whatever store on
fire okay but why isn't the entire
Republican Party who is after Koch
Industries pretty specifically it's not
totally unprecedented and it was rightly
called out this is absolutely enough
intimate to everything that I knew about
free-market conservatives slash work and
keep in mind that there were government
workers who negotiated this contract so
what is the status of their
responsibility for Amazon getting to
suppose a deal that the president I
don't even know if they got a deal no we
don't know what the deal is all we know
is that something is happening and
office has to charge to cover its cost
I don't think the post office is allowed
to give a cut-rate deal to anybody well
we all know that the government has
always thought follow the rules so we'll
just have to see if we get that contract
and we're going to order several books
from different places